Most Americans have come around to
believing that COVID-19 originated
in a lab and not in a wet market
in Wuhan, as China's CDC
claimed in March of 2020.
The former director of the CDC has
come around to believing that a lab
origin is more likely, as has the
former head of the Lancet medical
journals, COVID-19 Commission.
But I chaired the Commission for
the Lancet for two years on COVID.
I'm pretty convinced it came out
of the US lab of biotechnology,
not out of nature.
Journalists and scientists routinely
dismissed the lab leak hypothesis as
a crackpot theory up until the
summer of 2021, when science
journalist Nicholas Wade published
an influential article and a
viral rant by Jon Stewart.
The disease is the same
name as the lab.
Pushed it into the mainstream.
Up until that point, social media
platforms had been removing or
throttling posts that took a
seriously.
Anthony Fauci and NIH director
Francis Collins said it wasn't even
worth considering the possibility
that COVID could have originated in
the lab.
He tells National Geographic.
Everything about the stepwise
evolution over time strongly
indicates that this virus evolved in
nature and then jumped species.
Fauci added he does not believe
another theory that the virus
occurred naturally but was
accidentally released into the
public from a lab in China.
More recently, emails made public
through the Freedom of Information
Act have revealed that Fauci,
Collins, and other prominent public
officials took the possibility of a
lab leak origin far more
seriously than they were letting on.
Top virologists sort of giants
in this field.
We're looking at the genome and
I mean freaking out, basically.
Reporter Emily Kopp works at the
nonprofit U.S.
Right to Know, an organization
that has obtained thousands of pages
of official documents, of
correspondence, some of which
revealed an orchestrated effort
by scientists to downplay
the lab leak theory.
They've also extensively analyzed
emails obtained via a lawsuit by
BuzzFeed's Jason Leopold
that reveal the huge disconnect
between what health officials were
telling the public and what they
were saying in private.
I think this is a really
important question and
a really central part of this entire
story that maybe is not
talked about enough.
The fact that so many
mainstream publications have
completely overlooked
really key pieces of evidence
in this story.
And my
theory, and I think about this a
lot, is essentially that,
you know, health editors, the people
who are making decisions about what
to cover and what not to cover at
major news organizations, at least
when it comes to the Health Beat,
are friends with Anthony
Fauci. They've known him for,
you know, decades in some in some
cases.
And it's
probably very challenging to
examine
the possibility
that research funded
by Fauci's Institute
might have had unintentional
consequences.
And so
essentially, I think, to
put it very starkly, we see a lot
of health editors and health
reporters prioritizing
a tidy narrative about
Anthony Fauci over,
you know, providing the truth to
their readers.
And I think readers
deserve to understand the
full scope of possibilities
when it comes to the origins of
the pandemic.
Kopp has assembled a comprehensive
timeline that lays out substantial
evidence that Fauci,
Collins, and a number of influential
scientists misled the
public. Whether or not the lab leak
theory is correct, it's
now clear that these public
officials concealed their conflicts
of interest with the Wuhan Institute
of Virology and minimized
their own roles in providing the
government funding for the
unsupervised gain of function
research that may have led to the
pandemic.
Among other things, Kopp's research
has revealed that virologist
Kristian Andersen wrote privately
to Fauci that he and three
other scientists thought that the
virus that causes COVID-19
looked unnatural and inconsistent
with expectations from evolutionary
theory. Just four days later,
after participating in a series of
teleconferences with Fauci and
Collins, Andersen called the Lab
Leak Theory Crackpot.
Other emails revealed that Fauci
knew that his agency was funding
gain of function research
with SARS-likecoronaviruses in Wuhan
by late January of 2020.
Yet he publicly denied it before
Congress.
18 months later.
Will you today finally take some
responsibility for funding gain
of function research in Wuhan?
Senator, with all due respect, I
disagree with so many of the things
that you've said.
First of all, gain of function
is a very nebulous term.
Kopp works for the nonprofit US
Right to Know, which is devoting
significant resources to its
biohazards project with
the mission of investigating the
origins of COVID-19, the risks
of gain of function research, and
mishaps of Biolabs where pathogens
of pandemic potential are stored
and manipulated.